with its freedom of speech award or
Savannah recognized the White House
Correspondents Association efforts to
aport high reporting standards in a
challenging political environment
fifteen this price is recognition for a
free press worldwide and in the u.s. by
awarding it we are encouraging and
showing our solidarity with our
colleagues who have the task of
critically following the u.s.
president's political actions no not you
not you your organization's terrible
thank you much mr. president
and look where are you from BBC good
here's another beauty
why is they quiet mr. president like go
ahead you say can't ask it a question no
personal like can you give us a close
beer attacking us
can you give us a question be when you
get a shitty question I'm not gonna give
you a question you say can you are fake
news journalists in the United States
are under attack and being silenced by
the president they're supposed to be
holding to account respect Trump's
preferred mode of communication as
Twitter bypassing the mainstream media
whether online or in his speeches if
Donald Trump doesn't like the coverage
he doesn't work back you're fighting the
fake news it's fake phony fake the White
House Correspondents Association has
represented journalists covering the US
president for more than a century for
Jeff Mason that's Roy today is more
important than ever protecting
correspondence rights and making sure
they can do their job in Washington and
beyond
being here helps advance the cause of
transparency and the urgent need for
journalists and citizens to be able to
express themselves and hold their
leaders accountable then it is in that
spirit that I humbly and gratefully on
behalf of the White House Correspondents
Association accept this award Jack Mason
and his colleagues are determined to
keep reporting the facts and asking the
critical questions their award from
Germany is a sign that the world is
watching what happens in the White House
press room very closely
[Applause]